[Music]
back everybody we've got the legendary
Carol Burnett with us
up here with something Carol liked to do
on her show and her comedy specials
which we love which is take questions
from the audience all right let's turn
to our audience for their questions
right now so who has a question for
Carol oh everybody has a question for
Carol all right well I'm just do we want
to pick do I want to pick I get to pick
I'm gonna pick you right here in the
blue how about that
hi Carol hi in the 90 years that you've
been on this planet what would you say
is the most important thing you've
learned
oh that's a big question do you have
about 40 hours
not to take yourself too seriously not
to take yourself too seriously okay
check okay I'm gonna go with orange back
there yeah with the cool red hair come
on now hi
outside of entertainment what do you
still want to accomplish in your life
want to accomplish George Clooney
[Applause]
oh my God
it's my favorite part of this whole show
[Music]
[Applause]
guys I'm going
[Music]